Regarding cancer in infrared sonas, can I go to my local tanning facility that offers
infrared sonas, or do I need to go elsewhere?
Yeah, if you want to do a sauna at the local tanning facility, sure, you could do an infrared
sona there.
If it's a small little business and they have infrared sonas, for sure.
Go ahead and do that.
That's fine.
Yeah, and remember, you know, there's lots of different types of sonas out there.
Doesn't have to be near infrared or far infrared or mixed infrared.
A lot of the companies that sell sonas really taught, you know, they're selling their sonas
so they might advertise all sorts of different types of infrared and their sonas and stuff.
But the truth is there's really very little true infrared,
whether it's far or near infrared in any of these sonas.
So don't worry about that.
You're not using the sonas to get infrared.
Well, I can see the red light coming out of the plate that's a far infrared sona.
Okay, well, then if it's a red light, it's not infrared.
So infrared, far infrared and dear infrared will not have a color.
It's below the red light spectrum.
So if it is a red light, that is just red light.
Is that red light therapy beneficial?
Oh, baby.
I don't even know what the nano meters of the red light that is being showed might just be a colored light.
It's not really doing anything to help you.
It's the heat of the sona that's beneficial.
You're increasing your body temperature.
So you're sweating.
So your detoxifying through your pores has really nothing to do with whether it's infrared or not.
People ask that other question.
Can I just go to an old steam sona?
And you know, an old one where you pour, you know, the water on the rocks.
And you don't have to pour water on the rocks if you don't want to steam,
but it's just an old heat source sona.
Yes, does the same thing.
You're not getting any increase benefit no matter what the company does who sell it.
What the company says in their advertisements that sell the sonas.
There's really no infrared in the sonas.
We have that true infrared heating infrared source that we sell that hyperthermia that we sell.
Don't sell very many of them.
It's not necessary for most people.
And it doesn't go that deep.
It only goes an inch or two deep.
So if you have a tumor site that's deeper than that, it's not going to do anything for you.
It's really for breast cancer.
It's a good application for.
However, there's no light that comes from it because it's 100% true infrared.
So it doesn't show a light.
Plus it doesn't really heat that much.
It's just warming at best.
So it's not a source of heat.
So it's not a just false information out there, especially by these companies that maybe it's 1% infrared.
It's actually being produced.
But it's just a source of heat.